what were the fears at that time I'm
sure there were definitely all the the
pros of people thinking oh new ways to
tell stories but I imagine their people
were very fearful of this new method
well there were the first show for
example like it is said who knows if
this is true but it is claimed that when
they first saw this train arriving a
little suburban station in the South of
France la co-taught is the name of the
city people saw the train coming at them
on 10 because they're afraid the
trainer's came right off the screen it's
unbelievable to us but there was that
level of reaction the other kind of fear
was that from the producers point of
view this whole thing would last Lumiere
brothers who really in large part with
Edison and others invented the business
got out of it real quick because their
fear was it was incredible money drain
that nothing whatever happened to the
stuff that there was no future in movies
and they wouldn't even sell a Cameron
anybody because was pointless it was
just a little demo that they ran and it
wouldn't go anywhere so there were those
kinds of certainly those kinds of fears
you